hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Monday
what the [__] do I usually say I [__]
up to Cadence there what's going on it's
Phil first time for the Thursday
afternoon just before Friday that's it
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday Morning podcast and I am in a
[__] hotel room echo echo with the
loudest [__] air conditioner I've
ever heard in my life
and I'm not shutting it off what are
they got set 272 that's nice I can live
with that
I love when you're going to these
[__] hotel rooms and they got it like
set at 68 just crank it there's nobody
in there
you'd think these corporate [__] right
how they try to squeeze every [__]
dollar out of you and nobody ever
figures out that it's a corporate [__]
they never do they they blame everything
but the corporate [__]
you know
I saw this clip the other day like they
they only all they do is they if they
got a name that's what the [__] they
hanging on
I saw this thing where this actor was
talking about like the difference
between making movies now
and making movies like 20 years ago
where you had like the DVDs and all of
that [__] and so
if you're looking to make a movie for
this amount of money you know it's not
like the old days where you could also
depend on the DVD sales and blah blah
blah and all that and everybody's like
easy solution pay the actors less
[Laughter]
ah
I love
how dumb people
they just life is so easy for dumb
people they just they [__] everything
why don't you just [__] do this
and they throw their hands up like how
[__] hard was that like I figured it
all out
I figured it all out I'll tell you what
I figured out is that [__] air
conditioner is going to be too goddamn
loud
for this uh for the podcast off
oh you know something I like a [__]
air conditioner that shuts right off
they usually they go you know you shut
them off and they're like it's like
sending your kid to bed go to bed you
know it's like a 20 minute Pro
cess
um yeah it's 72 degrees I like that
usually you walk in they have it at 68
66 south of the Mason-Dixon line where a
government ain't telling me how [__]
chilly I can be right
why would you bring up the Civil War
Bill why would you do that all right
I would say though
like you know what shape people are in
by what what they have the air
conditioner set at at the hotel you know
72 degrees
I'm in Lincoln California
um Lincoln California home of this
[__] Casino I'm performing at is just
North
of Sacramento AKA Sac town
AKA hella something or other whatever
the [__] they say up here it's at 72
degrees so I'm expecting people to be in
decent shape
right if you go into a hotel room and
the air conditioner is set at 68 66 I
mean 66 that's for special places
like Houston
you know
where people are so fat and it gets so
[__] hot
that like
you know people just die like right now
there's just people dying in the streets
Houston Texas is 105 [__] degrees out
I got a buddy versus down there working
right who by the way is just getting
standing ovations all around the [__]
country everywhere he performs at that
[__] guy
is uh is on a whole other level and I
knew he was going to go to a whole other
level like
a couple years before the big pandemic
there I saw him at Gotham when he had to
stretch and you know he'd been opening
for me but I only get to see him do 10
15. I saw him do a half hour and I was
like all right this is over this guy's
gonna [__]
and that's going to be rocket fuel right
there so anyway
yeah it's 105 degrees in [__] Texas
down there in Houston man
Jesus Christ
you know California gets like that where
I live in Los Angeles for like [__]
every year it's like a little bit longer
you speak like two three days now it's
like 10 days 10 days and uh it's [__]
nuts like nobody's deal you know
everybody's like [__] global warming
shit's getting a little scary right no
Solutions we will figure it out that
that's what you say when you have kids
they're gonna figure it out they you
know they're gonna figure something out
I don't know if they're gonna figure it
out I don't know I have no idea but all
I know now is the move
that people do now there's like
so everybody like fries
for like two weeks out in LA and you're
like oh my God you know
like
is this the end of the world you know
it's like that level hot just
non-fucking like you wake up at like
[__] seven in the morning if you got
kids or if you have a real job right you
get up that early and it's already like
too hot to go outside you're like you
got to be [__] kidding me
so now the new move
for the limousine liberals out there is
they just leave
you know like how when I lived in
Manhattan
the super rich
it was amazing like the summertime it
would get so [__] hot
uh oh down in the subway platforms like
I still remember there was this time I
was doing this gig
either up in the Bronx or out in
Brooklyn or whatever and I had to go
I had to take the b or the D and it was
underneath the ANC line so I had to go
two levels down in the subway in like on
like July 31st
and
it was one of the safest places in New
York because it was too hot to do
anything other than just [__] stand
there
like
if you were like a crazy homeless person
if you started having like a manic
episode like you literally would have
just [__] died swinging your arms
around everyone like you ever go I you
ever have an apartment that's actually
an attic the top of a house and there's
no air conditioning I lived in one of
those one time and I remember in the
morning the [__] house flies would be
the size of your eyeballs and they would
be
all over and you couldn't [__] kill
him he'd have like a dish rag you know
because
you know you didn't have a fly swatter
because that was extra [__] money and
you live in the top of a [__] house
you know one of those uh Murder She
Wrote houses that just the heat just
sits up there
my friends used to call the apartment
the triangle and it was two levels to it
when you first walked in you had to walk
right down the center of your head would
hit either side on the ceiling and then
it opened up to a bigger
you know
I don't know I don't know what the [__]
it was like what about like eight foot
triangle as opposed to the other one was
like a five foot or six foot [__]
triangle anyway in the morning the Flies
will be [__] you couldn't get them
and then me and my brother would go to
work
uh
and we would just shut the door and all
the [__] windows and these things
would just bake in there all day long
and by the time you got home eight hours
later nine hours later with the lunch
hour the [__] flies you could
literally pick them out of the air just
walk up to him and just just flick them
across the [__] room
I have to tell you this story so we
didn't have any air conditioning so my
move was in the six foot part of the
triangle
because it was an attic you know when
addicts in those old houses like the
window was at floor level so I used to
sleep in a sleeping bag
I had no furniture oh my God I owned
nothing I had an old pickup truck
a Ford [__] Ranger
my life was so simple and I just had my
jeans in a pile my shirts in a pile and
my socks and underwears not even any
containers just
sitting there and then I had this orange
sleeping bag
hahaha
and I used to sleep in that thing
right next to the [__] window and it
was so frustrating
I didn't understand cross ventilation I
didn't understand air pressure what we
should have done was on both ends open
the maybe you couldn't on the front to
get the [__] cooler air from the
outside
to push that hot air out right
or a window fan something to get it
circulating we would just [__] be
sitting in there I remember I would go
to sleep
and I would just
I laid on top of the [__] sleeping
bag because it was so [__] hot and I
would just be like pressed up against
the [__] screen
laughs
and every once in a while there'd be a
breeze and I'd be like oh
and then I'd [__] pass out and
somewhere around three in the morning
you'd wake up like shivering because the
[__] cold air finally came in and
then I would just get in the sleeping
bag
and then that was it and uh so one night
I'm sleeping on top of the [__]
sleeping bag and I finally go to sleep
and I'm just in there my [__] tighty
whities because it was the 80s this is
before boxers came in so I'm laying
there
my whole body the color of my tighty
whities the only pigment is the one red
line that went around the band of my
tighty whities
so I fall asleep
and when I was asleep I always said I
was having this [__] up dream about
swimming or something I woke up and it
was like this [__] monsoon going on
and you know when it's raining so hard
with the wind it's blowing sideways I
was absolutely [__] drenched and I
was shivering I had to [__] get up I
went in the bathroom
I just had this old awful [__]
scratchy towel dried myself off and the
next morning
yeah because I couldn't sleep in the
sleeping bag because it was soaking wet
I kind of slept over by my [__]
clothes just grabbed like a pile of
shirts for [__] pillows
because my pillow was all soaked and the
next morning I woke up and it was
already 90 degrees out and I had a
[__] cold it was the [__] worst
and I came to work like it's good sleepy
baby [__] window right now I tried to
unload trucks
ah you know what's funny about a summer
cold though I got over it really quickly
it wasn't like the winter ones that just
hang around for like the whole week it
was kind of over it was like a 48 hour
cold or whatever but anyway
why am I talking about this [__]
um
oh because I was near somebody that had
that [__] got covered
so I feel fine I'm testing negative but
I got on the plane I wore a mask and
everything
I miss wearing the mask I like the mask
mask with the [__] hat on
nobody talking to you very anti-social
you know
slash your little you feel a little
mysterious like oh who is that
does he know something that I don't
um
anyway so
that's my life so now I'm in this
[__] hotel room over the next couple
of days
and uh I'm gonna do some shows up here
in Sacramento I'm very excited about
this I got the new hour is cranking and
I also went out I got some new symbols
for my drum kit
you know I've always played like
zildjianese or like say whatever
sabian's version of that is I always
played brighter symbols and I've just
been hearing more dark sounds in my head
um not like depressive just the stuff
I've been listening to I don't know what
so
um
I'm gonna uh anyways I bought
it was funny I thought about a ride and
I bought a CR I didn't buy the guy
[__] hooked me up what am I talking
about I got hooked up through Dave elich
and um I ended up getting two rides I
didn't get a crash but they're both so
like
you know you can crash on so they're not
bad
but I might go back and get another one
um
that anyway new hi-hats the whole thing
but I got the clear heads so my Toms are
really deep and they're kind of not
matching with the symbols I got so when
I get back
I'm going to go over to Pro drum on Vine
the best drum shop out there if not in
the country and I'm going to get some
coated heads put them on there crank
them up
and uh
I don't know just [__]
I like doing that Bebop style drumming I
don't know what the [__] it is I've
always
approached it and getting close get a
little more Independence and then I just
get distracted with other [__] and now
it's like I'm gonna [__] do that in
fact I actually brought the book
out on the road with me
my favorite one of my favorite drum
books of all time
yeah unzip in the bag my wife bought me
a new [__] bag
a new backpack for years she's been
telling me I think you need a new
backpack and I'm like why this one's
fine it was an Adidas one
and the a fell off
and I said I does or whatever the [__]
and it just got all the way down all I
had left was the D
and she just got sick of looking at it
so for my birthday she bought me a new
backpack you know acting like she was
doing something for me but she was
really doing it for herself because she
was sick of looking at it oh the art of
Bob drumming
by John Reilly not John C Reilly who's
an amazing musician himself
and actor and anything else he seems he
that he puts his mind to it's John
Reilly and forever I've been on
uh comp example four
and
you know it's says compact disc 12 and
compact disc 13 and I finally got to the
point where I can play these things
and kind of hear him in my head and now
there's like on these other Pages
there's sort of like these two bar
phrases and some soloing ideas
you know swinging 16th and triplets and
[__] and
um I don't know what it is about jazz
Drummond for some reason like I actually
think about what I'm playing and ideas
go into my head and because like I just
feel like playing Rock drums is like
your whole body
like constantly if you're playing a
Groove and it's you know snare kick hat
snare kick ride whatever the [__] you're
doing it's kind you know you have left
foots like tapping on the hi-hat I just
kind of feel like your body's already
preoccupied
and uh
but with jazz you know with the yes
Fred Armisen would do right it's just on
the symbol so you just kind of have that
then you can kind of comment with the
drums between the hands and the feet and
you start hearing [__] and what I like
too is when you play along with the Jazz
record it's it's not like you know when
I play along to like Joey Kramer or John
Bonham or stuff where I'm really
listening what are they playing and then
I just try to just do what they do
like because there's so much improv
going on
with jazz drumming that like there's no
real way to just do a cover like he
wouldn't just [__] play exactly what
they let me take you forever
because you know they just
doing whatever egg and the horn player
on or whatever and it's just like all
right
and for the first time ever it's kind of
opened my brain up to actually kind of
listen to what the hell I'm playing so
um
that's what I'm going to be doing this
summer I have no other things to do
other than just do my stand up hang out
with my kids and try out these new
symbols so I'm excited about that but I
also you know I'm rehabbing my shoulder
and doing what not
um
my son was so freaking cute when I went
to leave
he does this thing he goes Dada where
you going ugh breaks my heart every time
and then he goes to take my hand and try
to pull me back into the house or he
tries to take my hat off because you
know it's when I put my hat on it means
I'm going outside because I'm a little
bald there
don't want to get the old age spots on
the head there right so
um
yeah it was funny he actually before I
left gave me
one of you know the hug you always want
as a parent because usually they come up
and they give you a hug and the second
they hug you and you're sinking into oh
my God this is the greatest thing ever I
love this kid so much the second I mean
like literally 0.3 seconds into the hug
they turn around they point to something
else they want to do they just won't
hang in there for the hug but he knew
that I was leaving
so
he was hugging me and wasn't letting me
go so but I was leaving so it was sad
kind of sucked but I did get the hug out
of it
um
my daughter's hilarious though now I'm
like yeah I gotta go do a couple Road
gigs she's like all right see you
[Laughter]
don't let the door hit you in the
backside I'll see you later
um
so anyway
Oh Billy [__] uh Little Billy Botox
is gonna try to go down to the gym hit
the elliptical do a little list a little
[__] that
over the next couple days at this casino
I am out I am out here in this it's not
really the sticks I just don't have a
[__] car so
we'll see uh we'll see what's gonna
happen though but I'm working with uh
Dean Del Rey and the mighty
the Mighty Joe bartnick who by the way I
gotta tell you guys something he has a
[__] stand-up special we'll start all
things comedy he did it last year Ben
tishler directed it
and
um I knew it the night when I saw him do
it I'm like this special is actually
special
and he [__] killed so hard in the
first one that he came out on the second
one and killed even harder and that's
the one that they used
and uh
we're starting to release some clips
towards the end of the summer the whole
special's coming out I'm gonna have Joe
on my podcast you got to go see this guy
[__] live I was joking with him I was
thinking about how to sell his stand-up
special
and I joked with him today at the
airport I was like if you watch Prof if
you watch the NHL for the fights
uh you're gonna like this stand-up
specials
um gloves off Joe bartner because he's
always done well it just the first time
I ever saw Joe do stand up
Molly from the punch line in San
Francisco Joe is living in San Francisco
and uh I was in the green room and she
goes you know she'd always pick
comedians she would have this Knack of
putting the right people to open with
the right Comics coming into town
where
you know the opening act complemented
the headliners act but nobody was
stepping on anybody's toes
so she knocked in the door she goes uh
you know this guy Joe I want you to see
him come here just just watch some of
Zach tell me what you think and within
two jokes I was like oh my God I love
this guy and he was completely
Unapologetic
and just absolutely destroyed so all
these years later to do a special with
them I'm so [__] excited about this
thing
um we have one of the clips up right now
on all things comedy him talking about
that bar rescue guy
um
it's yeah it's and the special and the
way Joe looks it's like is this from a
long time ago did this just come it's
like all at the same time it's like
right now in a throwback all in the best
way so definitely uh check that out and
then we got another special out
um we're releasing clips for it was Nate
Craig another completely different style
but absolutely Nate is an absolutely
brilliant comedian
and
um I always get all kinds of messages
whenever he works on one of my shows
it's always like hey good job who the
hell was that first guy yada yada so
um having him coming out so we're going
to be promoting that over the summer
time so if you guys can check them out
look for the clips and then eventually
we'll put out the whole special because
that's the way the kids like to consume
it now they like the clips so uh we
ain't gonna fight it that's how we're
gonna do it there
um
oh my God I saw another car that I swear
to God I would buy in a [__] second
that I would buy in a [__] second I
posted it on my Instagram I think it's
still up on my stories you gotta check
it out
if you came up in the 80s
it's a 1986 Oldsmobile Cutlass 442 with
the [__] t-tops and those Factory mag
wheels that it had and the cloth
interior
I cannot even [__] tell you
how much I love that car
when I was a kid what I really loved was
the guy that drove it
the guy that drove it was everything
that I wanted to be
you know he had a mullet he could get a
tan he wore tank tops he was [__]
yoked he probably dealed weed and then
he had some smoking peroxide blonde in
the passenger seat
you know just getting blown driving down
to the cape
and I would tell you right now if you
missed it you missed it and as far as I
know we all wanted to be that guy
there were three there was basically
there was two camps this is some white
guy's [__] this is some inside white
guy's [__] here
all right there was two camps there was
the [__] you either wanted
a Camaro Z28
or the [__] Trans Am now personally
speaking I thought the Trans Am was
better
I thought
the Z28 everybody had that car but a
select few
had the Trans Am and even though it was
the same body same GM I thought the
Pontiac was better
um
so you that there was that camp
as far as sports cars went
and then on the other side
if you were a little more like you like
to cruise around town you know what I
mean I I don't know like
you weren't necessarily racing but you
wanted like a badass car but you also
you know
wanted to take some chick out to the
Ground Round you know so for some fine
dining with wood shavings on the ground
you either had the Oldsmobile Cutlass
if you had the 442 you were a [__]
Legend
which I always forget what that meant it
was like
a four barrel something else dual
exhaust
was it four speed four barrel four speed
dual exhaust something like that I don't
remember and okay so there was the
Oldsmobile Cutlass the Buick Regal
or the Monte Carlo and Monte Carlo Chevy
just dominated Chevy [__] dominated
so everybody wanted a month dude he's
got Imani you know and this is before
the the Monte Carlo SS came out they
brought that back I want to say in like
85 but like
you know
if you had like an 82 or an 83 or an 81
Monte Carlo
you know they had a black with like the
red seats and they started putting
t-tops in them and the Buick Regal they
always kept that one you know that was
always a little more refined that was
actually for an actual adult
as opposed to somebody you know I mean
dude that was just totally the Gold's
Gym
you know maybe you did a cycle or maybe
you are that natural I don't know you
know you had the [__] tank top with
like it just it was open on all the way
down to like your [__] waist
the big puffy pants
it was fun I used you know when you had
the [__] Macho Man Randy Savage
[__] I'm painting a picture here
People Macho Man Randy Savage glasses
you had to Mullet down the back with the
flat top on top
I mean like
you were just crushing it
on on like an insane [__] level
always had some a 12 pack or a [__]
joint behind your ear
and uh
you know just driving down the [__]
Street
listening to The Outfield
you know T is for Fears because your
girlfriend wanted to listen to it
it was just incredible right so anyways
here it is 40 years later almost
and uh
ice somebody posted this [__]
Oldsmobile 442 it immediately sold
and uh the thing about like two of the
cars that I love the most in the 80s
is uh later generations loved them too
and like I love the uh the Chevy Caprice
Classic
four-door sedan but uh Latino Community
loves that car and a lot of them the
ones that have survived they're turned
into low riders so it's kind of hard to
find like a stock one
um they look sick as a low rider like I
I um
I'm a huge fan of like the the [__]
you know those lace tops like the
painting
of the cars with low riders it's just
like on a whole other [__] level
um but I like the stock looking one and
then the uh the cars I was talking about
the Oldsmobiles the Buick Regals the
[__] Monte Carlos those are the ones
like the black dudes down in Atlanta
with they put the giant [__] tires on
them or whatever so it's kind of hard to
find like a stock one
because everybody likes doing that to
those both of those cars but uh this was
a stock Oldsmobile 442 I have it in my
my stories
um
um oh my God
I wonder if I could just rent one that's
my new thing because I look up I'm like
oh [__] I should just sell my daily
driver and get that thing but then you
have that thing and then you just like
[__] you know now I got to get it fixed
it's leaking I gotta deal with all of
this [__] right
um
the lovely Neo really changed my mind
about that where
you know there's two types of people
there's there's the people that [__]
buy them
um and and then there's two types of
buyers me where I buy one like I could
never get rid of my old truck I just
love it too much right but I I get like
emotionally attached to [__] so I always
Envy Dean Del Rey where he could get
something drive it it was cool and then
he'd get rid of it and then get
something else
you know I always thought that that was
[__] cool but I just I was getting
them and I just like nah man I [__]
love this car I want to keep it then I
love it so much I get worried that I'm
gonna sell it to the next person they're
gonna [__] it up or they're not going to
care about it
um
but that is definitely
you know oh I forgot to say with the
Buick Regal so that was like for more
like a [__] you know
an adult would kind of drive that car
and then out of nowhere
I think when the Monte Carlo SS when
they brought back that line
uh the Buick Regal shut everybody down
with the Grand National
and uh
that car was so fast for that era it
wasn't really fast especially for now
like
you know what's funny right now is is
like the cars are so goddamn fast
the gas combustion ones forget about the
[__] electric ones those things are
insane there's like more horsepower than
brains out there so there's just people
[__]
I mean you could just watch endless
videos of people [__] up their car
because they lose the rear end but most
of them are I think nowadays a
front-wheel drive so you're kind of are
right with that but like
um the [__] speed of some of these
cars that are coming out it's really a
[__] glorious time
so I will say you know if we are going
to heat up the planet we are kind of
doing it in the in the in the best way
possible
um
so anyway
I don't know that's I hope you guys
enjoyed me going down [__] Memory
Lane uh I forget what those things were
called what bodies type that body type
that was I remember the uh
there was a certain body type too for
the Camaros and the Trans Ams the F-type
I don't know what the [__] it was but I
am now
no I'm gonna go to the gym but after I
do that before my show I'm going to go
onto the internet
and I'm just going to look up [__]
mid 80s Oldsmobile Cutlass 442s
and if you're young listening to this
you're going to do the same thing God
willing
if you live long enough all the [__]
that you have now you're gonna go back
and just look up like oh like I don't
know what you guys look up old laptops
and PlayStations and iPads and it's
gonna mean something to you because it's
going to be a part of your life where
you weren't married you didn't have any
kids no responsibility no ailment no
debt none of that [__]
and uh
so it was it'll just it'll remind you of
a simpler time almost like a a comfort
food and then also I got to give a uh
I got a uh
give a shout out to this comedian I saw
he did this [__] amazing bit
um look up at Pat Bircher
b-u-r-t-s-c-h-e-r
it says at Pat birchard Uh Bircher uh
solve the economic problem
uh uh this [__] [__] killed me it
absolutely [__] killed me
um and his style is amazing
definitely check him out all right
that's it I hope you guys are all good
have a great weekend you [__] and uh
enjoy the music that the
amazingly talented Andrew females
uh
uh is put in here so don't ever give me
credit it's always Andrew with the great
music and um and then enjoy uh a bonus
episode of the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday Morning podcast
[Music]
hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's the Monday Morning podcast for
Monday
June 28th uh 2015. how you doing how are
ya
how are you how are you how are [__]
you
um I am completely burnt out I'm at the
end of my tour right now and uh I have
to leave for my show in Tucson in
exactly one hour so I'm going to do a
half hour of this podcast and then do my
show and then I'm gonna finish it up
after the show so what you're basically
going to have is Stone sober me doing
the first 30 minutes and then a slightly
more a slightly older slightly wiser
slightly more buzzed
um
Billy redface doing the second half of
the podcast because that's how this is
going down and I have to be somewhere
immediately of course the second I
[__] land because that's how it works
um in this business it's how it works so
I think oh you're gonna have a little
breather there you're gonna have a
breather let's just [__] yank that
right off the table but it could always
be worse I could have absolutely nothing
to do staring at a phone like that crazy
[__] in that movie The Audition you
guys ever see that
remember that she was sticking the
needles in there [__]
that's what you get for trying to bang
some crazy actress
you know they're not sticking needles
into you literally right listen to me
having the nerve to act like I'm I'm
even remotely sane
so anyways uh this is the last night of
the tour I want to thank everybody
that's come out on this one and I want
to thank Joe bartnick for absolutely
crushing it
right up until uh
Wednesday
Bakersfield the last one and then
[__] uh Jay lawhead came in
after [__] Barton it gave me a strong
seven Innings I went to the bullpen you
know
he gave me six and two thirds then he
walked the next batter then I brought
him [__] brought in law head law had
crushed it and um
it was a crazy week of shows then we did
uh
did some place in the Inland Empire and
uh 98 of the people were cool there and
then there was just some of the drunkest
[__] animals
I've ever been uh that I've been in
front of in a while I'm talking like
literally screaming and whistling during
setups like I wasn't even saying
anything
and I'd just be like well you know I've
been doing stand-up for a while and
something in the backup is like
just [__] whistling about what I
don't know I felt like I was doing like
a rock concert you know like when you
listen to a live album
and they'll end the song and one of
those mumbling jackass
singer-songwriters be like you know
we've been coming out here for a while
here oh yeah oh it's like dude he hasn't
said anything he's on his way to the
point and people are already screaming
because they're [__] wasted so my
apologies to the sober people
who are at that show that show was
[__] brutal I'll be honest with you
man that one was a lot of work with all
those screaming it was like 20 people
and they were in all different parts
of the uh the venue and they were
screaming and yelling and I finally
snapped in the end
and uh I don't know
and I said a word I shouldn't have said
you know what I mean
and then something the crowd like
related to it and then it came up to me
and they [__] gave me the tickets
back like oh you spending all this money
on him just and then through the whole
[__] tragedy of their life put it on
me I didn't know what the [__] they were
talking about
you know and it's just one of those
[__] things once again it's like dude
I talked about plane crashes I talked
about sinking cruise ships I made fun of
Bruce gender so I guess I gender Bruce
Jenner
so I mean it just laughed at me so I
mean technically it wasn't all of that
offensive no it was just the [__]
thing that that was that was about your
[__] life and not only that I just
said a word I didn't even do a bit on it
I basically said to the guy in the crowd
I said the guy was such a [__] [__]
I have 90 minutes of this guy if I
Snappers like dude are you [__]
[__] I never say that word and that
night I happened to say it in a moment
of [__] night now obviously I'm not
making fun of [__] uh uh um whatever
you [__] he's supposed to say mentally
challenged people why would I ever do
that and I've said in the past I didn't
see [__] people come up to me you
said the person don't do the [__]
show me a picture of that kid and just
put the whole [__] thing on me
and I want to apologize to the next 40
people in line because I was processing
what the [__] just happened and then I
got livid
the way they [__] handed me the
tickets back and I took them because I
didn't know what they were saying like
here throw these things out you're a
piece of [__] and you know it's like
it's like if they're listening 100 I
apologize and 100 go [__] yourself
let me guess let me guess you never said
anything [__] up right you never
laughed at something you shouldn't have
said you never lost your temper and
[__] said something if you don't dump
your whole [__] life on me like that
like I'm the worst [__] person ever
you know you are out of line
and not only that once I realized what
the [__] you were talking about I said
oh my God I'm so sorry I'm sorry that
guy was yelling I should have said it
blah blah and you just wouldn't accept
it you wouldn't [__] accept it you
had to have your moment so you know my
apologies and [__] you so that was that
night
anyways you know what I mean let me do
it some [__] up [__] happened to me
when I was a kid that I will not get
into but I've seen Comics joke about it
I don't give a [__]
I know they're not attacking me I know
they don't wish that misery on me
Jesus I'm on a comedy show right
it's Christ every [__] week you guys
call me a ginger 12 Ways to Sunday I
don't give a [__] do I think you'll
really hate me if you hated me you
wouldn't be writing in I get it you're
[__] around
yeah sorry I had to get that out I was
something I wasn't going to talk about
but if I didn't talk about it be [__]
flicking me in the back of my ear for
the rest of this podcast so anyways
oh my God
I was literally going like you know what
I'm never going out after a [__] show
again
that's how [__]
awful that whole goddamn moment was
all right
probably this is why I probably
shouldn't have talked about that because
now I'm [__]
I don't know I wish I didn't say it
why the [__] do they have to come that
night you know what are the [__] odds
what did that drunk have to be there
you know
if I just ended the show five minutes
before I would have said the ah this
just [__] kills you you know people
every everybody's got a [__] moment
now
you know what I mean it's like dude I'm
[__] driving through this country
right and you're just seeing all the
water out in California is that it
brutally low levels
and you know
old Tony Monsanto there everybody
[__] say Tony's [__] with the food
none of these [__] running for
president are going to talk about any of
that it's all going to be like the level
with which people are freaking out that
gay people can now get get married who
gives a [__]
who aren't like I don't understand
people trying to protect
you know what do they call the sanctity
of marriage or whatever these [__]
morons are talking about it's like dude
I don't know if you've noticed like 60
of them go down the [__] anyways you
know what I mean
maybe these gay people will be better at
it than straight people and they'll up
the numbers right
oh those poor bastards gay people God
bless you but I I don't think that you
realize what you [__] walked into
we want to do it too
Jesus Christ
you're not being married like being
married is like going on a ride at Six
Flags you know what I mean
it's fun it's [__] exciting but
there's like a there's this [__]
chance that one of the bolts is gonna
come off and you're gonna go flying into
the woods
have I ever told you guys about that I
don't go to I don't go to amusement
parks I absolutely refuse
you know maybe
you know Disneyland I would go to I've
gone to that but even then you go in
Space Mountain you're like how [__]
old is this ride
you know what I mean just there's always
something going on but you know I feel
like the stationary ones
are safer because you know where they're
at those ones where they pick it up and
put it down and then leave town you know
you're still FL you flew into the bushes
and they go all right let's wrap it up
and they get the [__] out of there
um
plus the wear and tear of putting them
together and taking them down and
everything ah man why the [__] did that
happen so that [__] just
I was a well that's the worst moment
I've had as a comedian in a long [__]
time because I I felt I really hurt
those people and I didn't want to do
that but then to the way they [__]
you know uh
just write my just the whole [__]
thing
and then it wasn't until I just wish in
the moment I could have said that so
like plane crashes are okay you're all
right with that cruise ships you're okay
cruise ship sinking that's fine
you know what I mean
me teasing [__] Caitlyn Jenner that's
fine that's not that all of that's funny
right oh I wish I had I always had a
[__] videotape of them sitting in the
crowd laughing at all of that [__]
and that [__] [__] that's what I
should have called them that was the
thing I wasn't even thinking about like
you know mentally challenged kids when I
said that I was basically just saying
why are you being such a [__] [__]
right and then some feminists will come
up to me
um I have one of those and it's called a
vagina and [__] sticks the goddamn
tickets back in my face
sorry Enlighten the [__] up how about
that how about that if you're going to
go to a comedy show if not you know stay
the [__] home go watch a lifetime
um anyways I'm gonna keep going back to
that I don't give a [__] till I get it
out of my [__] system so oh Billy
cardio went off the rails the last two
days
um
I stayed out late
you know so people that I work with uh
showed up when I was in Vegas surprised
me they're like ah let's go and get a
cigar so I was like all right so we went
out and uh stayed out till like five in
the morning and in the meantime my uh my
iPhone 4S
finally [__] the bed
you know bartnick was he had the 4S and
he finally switched to the six he was
saying he goes dude once that battery
starts cutting out you know it's gonna
get worse and worse and worse and it
finally [__] cut out and I plugged it
in and I was getting nothing so
you know the lovely knees like well we
got to get you a new phone
so uh
I went into Caesars Caesar's Palace next
door
where uh
they have all these beautiful shops and
everything and all these [__] animals
walking in and out of them like make you
know shuffling around [__] sweatpants
saw some guy in there was like true
legend pants and a t-shirt
did not see any Ed Hardy shirts Ed Hardy
shirts are gone I don't know what ocean
they're floating in right now I'm
guessing the Indian Ocean for some
[__] reason we can't dump it all in
the Pacific right I don't know where
those [__] Things Are
um but I guarantee you when they do the
uh the Fast Times at Ridgemont High or
some [__] or the Dazed and Confused of
this era they're going to have people
wearing those True Religion jeans or
maybe last decade I should say and the
Ed Hardy shirts
telling you dude that's why George
Carlin another reason why George Carlin
was a genius
you know is if you notice most of his
specials he wore just all black I mean
that's never going out of [__] Style
you know he probably figured that out
after he had his hippie dippy [__] that
he wore in the 70s you know what I mean
some of that stuff and you start looking
at like oh my god do I got flowers on my
jeans
why did I think that was cool because
everybody else did but they got rid of
theirs and there's videotape of you with
yours on so you look like the only
[__] that wore them you know so
um
anyways uh I'm all over the [__] map
here so uh dude Bakersfield was
tremendous
um trying to work my way back to think
where the hell we were oh I already
talked about I keep forgetting that I do
the Thursday podcast so you already
heard about that
um playing the Fox Theater and all that
and obviously no
Fresno California we're [__] around
you come up here
if you smile we're gonna push a cab
you're ready
um did that one and uh then we did two
nights at the Mirage
and uh
just had a [__] amazing time and um
tremendous crowds and uh so tonight's
the last one down here in Tucson Arizona
and it was like a seven hour drive down
here
we got up at like uh 9 A.M or something
like that drove all the way down here
and I gotta get
we gotta drive out of the venue here at
like 6 45 so
I'm gonna try to get through as much
maybe I'll do 45 minutes who knows last
15 of you guys are all like Bill cut it
off now get [__] faced and then do the
rest of the podcast
um
so anyways uh
oh here's something you know what's a
[__] pet peeve of mine in [__] uh
I don't know if this is just
about women or if it's Casino women I
have no idea
but women who uh at the end of the night
take off their high heels because their
feet hurt and they just start walking
down the street in their bare feet
are walking across the casino rug in
their bare feet you know bottom of their
feet all [__] dirty I was joking
about that at the Mirage I was like you
know what you can't you can't marry that
you can't marry that dude that's a
quitter
you know you you couldn't make it till
the last [__] 1500 yards up to your
room
you couldn't throw a pair of little
flippy flops into your clutch or
something like that what kind of a
[__] animal
you know I could only imagine I know
what women think about if you had to
walk around in those yeah you know I'd
have some flip-flops I would there's no
[__] way I would ever walk Barefoot
across the road people walk in and out
of the [__] men's in ladies room
with God knows you know what the [__]
goes on in there literally a [__] show a
[__] and piss show goes on in there
all kinds of bacteria and you're just
walking barefoot through it like you're
Christ
Jesus Christ you [__] girlfriends
gotta wash your feet when you come in it
just it just it's
that to me that takes a [__] 10 all
the way down to about
well if we're just talking sex who's
kidding who were nine and a half but if
we're talking about the mother of your
children it's just it's done it's a done
[__] deal if she is an adult if her
feet are gonna be that dirty how filthy
are your [__] kid's feet is going to
be been on this place yeah you want to
jump in on it grab a microphone
um
no like late at night that night we
stayed out uh Friday night and we ended
up at the uh the deli there trying to
grab me a microphone here
would that be in my bag
ah Christ I don't know where it is my
backpack yes
my pack that I put on my back
AKA my backpack
um
yeah me and Jay ended up in this uh they
got like this Carnegie Deli or Carnegie
depending if you're from the east coast
to the or the Midwest
I've noticed that in Pittsburgh it's
always Carnegie
East Coast it's Carnegie oh traveling
um
so we were there and these two girls got
into this who didn't have shoes on kind
of got in this drunken like sort of haha
little [__] play fight so one of them
kind of falls down and her legs go up in
the air like right up over the booth and
I was staying there waiting to order and
I just saw her the filthy soles of her
feet
and uh it just I I can't say it made me
lose my appetite it I don't know I'm
just I'm just babbling here because you
know what I'm doing I'm trying to find
the other [__] microphone
we brought in and you know we brought it
because you brought it
there it is no all right so it's down
here here it is oh there it is is this
an entertaining podcast this podcast has
now been renamed two people looking for
a microphone
Sonia when we finally get this hooked up
evidently you're going to weigh in on
this
yeah you want to weigh in on it you want
to have your two cents yes please
hey has Donald Trump been knocked out of
the race yet I'm really rooting that he
stays in the longest
just continue to be the most
entertaining person on it because
everybody else is going to go Al Gore
oh education we gotta we gotta do things
yeah hang on one second let's see what
we got here all right
check check check two two two check all
right so what are your feelings no I
want yeah talking about the uh dirty
women [__] Dirty Feet [__] yeah
here's the thing I I agree with you dbbs
if you can't dfbs your heels
that you don't need to be wearing them
that's really the bottom line and I know
you want to look cute I want to look
cute I want to wear high sexy gorgeous
heels that make my legs and [__]
[__] want to be looking cute
but if you can't handle it you need to
not wear them you need to save your
highest sexiest but most like goddamn
looking shoes that shows off your
pedicure when you have a date or
whatever when you're getting picked up
and you go in the car in the restaurant
back in the car back to the crib
otherwise you don't need to be wearing
if you're going out dancing you need to
find some cute shoes that are a lower
heel that you can dance in and you can
walk in yeah you don't look crazy
because I can't stand that either
whenever I see a woman walking around
with their bare feet I want to scream at
them like don't just don't do it you
know it's great too you know what's
great handle it don't do it and also
save your feet be smart it's not worth
it it's really not worth it looking like
what's the word I want to use could I
say something a trashy mess can I get a
word tracing through the casino with no
shoes on you know what else is great now
it's when they take the shoes off and
then just now they look like this little
Stumpy person in this short dress and
the illusion of all the other women
you're like oh my god look how long
those legs are you really start doing
the math you start knocking off a few
inches I have shoes that I wear if I'm
going to a concert well see the thing is
I I feel like if I go to a concert I'm
not doing that Standing Room [__]
because I'm too old for it anyway but I
have [__] if I'm going out this is
[__] up did I say that I'm not I
wouldn't marry someone that takes their
shoes off that's that's a lock the door
test that's a little extreme
yeah do any of your girlfriends are they
to take the shoes off people no they're
you know do you have any dirty feet
[__] in your crew no I don't have any
dirty feet [__] in my crew keep them
on or you don't wear them seriously
though well there you go so why the hell
would you [__] marry that and have a
kid
I don't know if you need to make the
leap from you take off your shoes to
equals I'm not gonna marry you that's
that's a bit of a that's a bit of a
stretch unbreedable Unbreakable hahaha
yeah you're done I might I might I might
have to add that into the [__] act as
far as like the people that you know
when I when I'm doing my cleanse of the
population so the Water Supply stays
where it needs to be oh that would be
another person I would get rid of women
who take their shoes off when the final
10 of the night aren't content to walk
down a public [__] Street you know
also women bare feet why don't you put
in inserts insoles into your shoes I
have insoles in all of my heels they get
the clear ones the Dr Scholls I know you
feel like an old lady going into that
section but I have them in every single
pair of heels because and even still
they hurt my [__] feet
dumb people why when they go out and go
do something you're asking them why
don't they do something smart yeah well
maybe because they're dumb who kind of
[__] Pro I don't give a [__] if I was
wearing snow shoes when we went there's
no [__] way I wouldn't I would I
would take those off and walk Barefoot
across the casino we went to the Michael
Jackson show those shoes that I was
wearing gorgeous amazing hurt my feet
expensive I put the insulin
unnecessary still hurt and I stuck it
out I stuck it [__] out because I
committed myself to wearing them and I
wasn't going to quit and I wasn't gonna
look like one of those girls because
that's messy that's sloppy you don't
want to look like that
[Music]
deal with it and if you can't hang then
don't by the way Michael Jackson's show
was amazing
amazing even with the Scooby-Doo kids
that was weird I thought it was for the
kids but I don't want to ruin the show
but at one point I challenge any person
to go to that show and at some point
you're not thinking just put on the
[__] hat
just put on the [__] hat I that
musical theater whoa I get it the Hat
has power put it on and do your [__]
dance already Jesus Christ it's a Cirque
du Soleil show it's called one it's
tremendous please go see the show and I
challenge you not to Time Magazine says
all right I'm gonna talk about it I
cried I'm gonna talk about hockey oh so
this is the part where I dip out right
and this is part way so thank you for
not being a a dirty feet [__] I love
you too
[__]
[__] so anyways uh oh let's talk NHL
hockey here Jesus Christ
the Bruins are going through a a whole
[__] rebuild here
I I you know what the only reason why
Dougie Hamilton getting traded did not
Shock me was because the first half of
this tour I I was I was working with Joe
bartnick who knows as much about hockey
as anybody on the NHL channel and he was
saying like uh
he was just doing his botnik thing just
saying like they should get rid of
Dougie Hamilton he's too much of a hit
on the cap you want to keep McQuade he's
a stay-at-home guy on defense he sticks
up for his teammate every team in the
NHL is looking for a guy like Adam
McQuaid that's the guy you keep Dougie's
too soft blah blah blah I was just
sitting there God I like him he's kind
of offensive but everything that he
[__] said then the guy gets shipped
off to Calgary I still loved him
but I never saw them Trading lucich
I mean that guy he's the [__]
locomotive
he's the toughest guy in our [__]
team and now he's gone
like
come on little cheeks going down
crashing the [__] Net who's gonna do
that now
you know putting Ryan Miller in his
place who's gonna do that now sorry
Buffalo fans I'm [__] with you I know
he got frustrated because he thought he
had a breakaway and it bounced over his
stick so he acted a little childish
there who's gonna stab someone in the
balls
when we need them too sorry I'm actually
bringing up his worst thing other than
that yeah he's a [__] Force so now he
goes to the Kinks
and to me once again the West is way
more [__] interesting than the east
how will Chicago respond
to that force of nature that is Milan
Lucci that's now with the Kings the only
thing I liked about the trade is I live
in LA so it's yet another reason to go
see that great team even though they
didn't make the playoffs last year so
um all I will say about this is I hope
the Bruins know what they're doing it's
the exact same thing I said about the
Patriots a couple years ago when they
they did I can't remember who the [__]
they traded I was just like I hope they
know what they're doing
and uh evidently they did because we
just won a Super Bowl so
um
you know at the end of the day when I'm
a [__] comedian what do I know about
building a goddamn team
I'll tell you right now I didn't like us
getting rid of our GM
the guy obviously did a great [__]
job he won a Stanley Cup he makes one
stupid comment and everybody listens to
Dan Shaughnessy who doesn't watch hockey
on any level I don't give a [__] they
need to make a move
does Dan Shaughnessy even write articles
anymore does he just take like [__]
articles he's already written a thousand
times and just pull [__] words out
and put new new
players names in there I don't I rip on
that guy too much you know what I mean I
rip on it too much but
the only time he really bugs me is when
he [__] uh
is when he when he trashes the Bruins
it's like dude you don't even know what
the [__] you're talking we don't watch
the goddamn sport all right
so just shut up then anyways
um
oh dude so he pulled in here to uh
Tucson Tucson Arizona
and uh we're driving down the street
we're a little bit lost
and we get into this [__] part of
[__] town
you know
and we're driving down the street in
this [__]
white trash looking dude walking up the
street just gives the finger to the bus
as we drive by
it's gone you see that guy he's giving
us the finger what's he give us the
finger for it's like Jesus Jay do the
math
look at the neighborhood what do you
think the [__] you think's happening
he's blaming his whole [__] life on
us rather than whatever got him into
that situation
be it racism or whatever well not racism
he's white I don't know what the [__] it
was but it wasn't the bus
[__] bus
um I'm not gonna lie to you maybe really
uncomfortable it's like uh should we be
driving through here in this thing maybe
we should take a [__] taxi
um
anyway so uh so here we are we got one I
gotta read some of this [__]
advertising
was it 6 15
it's one of the great things about being
a guy you take a shower in like [__]
three minutes
shake off like a goddamn Hound right
poor women got to go in there you know
on all that clown makeup put on their
shoes they're gonna make their feet
[__] hurt you know
it's a lot of advantages all right here
we go so there you go oh that's 31
minutes 31 minutes in all right so right
now I'm gonna hit pause and I'm gonna go
ah [__] that I can keep going here right
can I keep going no I should get off
oh she's saying it get off The Horn wait
a minute oh my God this [__] maniac
Jesus Christ you know do people know how
to be at a [__] show
certain people you hook up they're
[__] cool other people you hook up
and I'm here now I'm here oh now I'm
calling your phone is everything going
to be okay relax
tickets gonna be there you're gonna sit
there right your wife's gonna take off
her shoes get her feet all dirty you're
gonna slam a couple of [__] scotches
and I'm gonna get up there and do a
little [__] clown dance for you all
right
it's [__] an hour and 40 minutes
before the show I still I haven't even
put my red nose on yet
oh I was old Billy sport coach Saturday
night in Vegas came out there with a
pocket square and everything and I
actually stuck it up
and I wore the jacket for the whole show
oh my God this [__]
um and I wore the jacket for the whole
show even though it was starting to get
hot the only actually the only real
reason why I didn't take it off was
because I had a white shirt underneath
it and I'm pasty as [__] and uh
you know I didn't want to you know I
didn't want to be up there looking like
a head on top of a [__] candlestick
[Music]
um so anyways oh by the way
if you're just into working out you know
the that Michael Jackson show those
Cirque du Soleil people are [__]
unbelievable this one guy he does a
routine on this rope climbing this rope
up and down the [__] thing 80 80
[__] different ways for a whole song
if you can go up a climb roping climbing
rope climber up a climbing rope and come
back down using your feet
you know
that's impressive if you can do it
without using your feet that's even more
impressive but what this guy was doing
was just on a whole other level and then
the biggest beast of the show was this
one woman who came out and was basically
uh
one of the strongest human beings I've
ever seen in my life she was doing stuff
that just defied
even some of the stuff like I've seen
that um
like you ever see those guys like do
like the human flag
and then they'll do like this this woman
did
all of that and she would do it for like
five minute chunks she just didn't do it
and that's how you do the human flag and
then that's it she'd be in that position
for like 20 seconds and then go into
something even harder
I remember her finishing [__] move
she's upside down on on you know I guess
it's called a stripper pull you know but
what she did was so artistic we'll just
say it was like a street sign pole just
to give her some class there
um
pole dancing all right there you go
whatever
so she [__] was upside down in a full
split
with no hands
does that thing where you just sort of
let yourself slide down the pole and
then you stop yourself
when people do that with their hands
that's amazing she did it upside down in
a split and she did it with her legs
and a smile on her face that never
betrayed any sort of pain it was it was
the greatest display of uh I don't know
she was unbelievable she was unfucking
believable pick I can't say what I was
just going to say I would say picture so
and so in a bikini but that would have
been bad
um anyways all right
that's it for sober bill
hang in there and through the magic of
uh editing I will be back in about two
seconds and I'll be a little bit happier
maybe a little more hoarse in The Voice
and definitely a lot more uh well I'm
not buzzed at all right now I'll have a
couple of [__] I'll throw down a
couple you know whatever all right
go [__] yourself I'll talk to you in a
minute
all right now back the Magical Mystery
Tour
is coming to take you away I don't know
why that's in my [__] head and now
I'm not drunk I've had two Bud Lights
you know I might as well have some
raisin bran such a weak [__] beer
um all right so I did the last show and
uh great crowd and all that type of [__]
I had a wonderful time in this
conference room and uh thank you to
everybody who came out to the shows and
everybody came out to the tour
um and uh you know
and I'm gonna leave it at that because
uh yeah how do I not say it
I can't uh he was dead you know they
were having a yeah they were having one
of those days down there I can't say it
like yeah you know
yeah I don't wait what are you gonna
[__] do I don't know
that's not the way you go about it I sit
there and I act like everything was fine
no no no no no no you're not jumping on
this talking that [__] I'm not gonna
talk [__] yeah you are no no I'm not I'm
not doing it I'm not doing it shush the
man has spoken and he said woman
oh geez all right let's get into the
[__] questions here all right oh
question yeah you know I said one of
those days you know I'm still one of
those things that's why everything's all
[__] up all right Jack Williams
Jack Williams Billy Landsdowne Street
not sure if you heard this man's down
street yeah right down near Fairway
back in the day you wouldn't go down
there at night now you can skip down the
street you can
troll Allah I love Lansdowne Street used
to hang out there during college all
right WBZ 4 Boston news anchor Jack
Williams retired this week wow
I you know I'm afraid to see how old he
is it's gonna make me feel even [__]
older than I am can you please give a
short speech about him as though you
were at his retirement party
well as retiring parties I'd be half in
the bag yeah I would say stop that
[Laughter]
Dick Williams
[__] Jack
I love you man
[Laughter]
we're both redheads involved in this
business
I used to watch you when I was a kid and
you were 40 years Health you and Liz
Walker had a great rapport and uh you
always had a great sense of humor and
that stuff you did for the kids
Wednesday's Child again he's just I love
that guy I can't believe he's retired
that guy I'm not gonna act like I'm his
retirement party that guy was the best
he is the best total professional and he
was funny as hell and he had a great
sense of humor
um then the bet I used to watch them way
back in the day it was Jack Williams Liz
Walker and Bob Lobel did the sports and
that was it and then they throw it to
Bob no wire knew me they throw it to him
and that poor bastard I remember when we
used to go to Patriots games he did this
thing one year
for some stupid reason they thought this
would be a good idea and this is back
they've sent him to Sullivan Stadium
Sully it might even have been Schaefer
Stadium back then they wanted to do this
thing whenever the Patriots were right
down on the goal line they would record
him
you know
for the segments later on in the news
for him to be like you know and you know
and it's whatever 328 in the third
quarter the Patriots were down on the
one yard line and then they would just
he would turn around and then if they
scored
he'd say and Tony Collins ran the ball
in blah blah blah so he [__] would go
down there and we're all hammered and
he'd be taken a knee and we just wait
for his lips to start moving and we'd
all just start screaming [__] know me
no he beat down on one knee I remember
at one point he was looking like he was
getting upset and then he just sort of
just put the mic down like he had it in
his hand but he just sort of Let it go
down like that he just shook his head
and started laughing it's just like why
would you do that to the guy so anyways
um all three of them they were funny as
hell Bob newmeyer was great too and now
he does all the horse racing everything
so I know that Boston Legend
retires Jack Williams thank you for all
your great news class and uh the
Wednesday's Child and all that stuff you
were awesome so there you go I hope
other people gave a [__] about that who
weren't from Boston all right advice for
my daughter
yeah
uh top of the morning to you standard
redhead joke that everybody's done of
zillion time all right I want to thank
you in advance for any advice you have
from me or my daughter my daughter is
third I'm gonna say it the whole way
through is 13 and doesn't have many
interests at least none that she is
willing to stick with well she's only 13
dude the [__] she's gonna pick a career
he's screaming at her every night is it
going to be Finance you're going to be a
nurse mom
however there seems to be one subject
that keeps come coming up uh that she
asks my help with and that's comedy
she's a funny and Incredibly sarcastic
kid my favorite type of humor well she
probably got it from you but yeah I was
just about to say yeah oh cause she's
daddy's little sarcastic girl and she
wants to learn how to write jokes I have
searched for classes but they appear to
be given at a comedy club and I don't
think they would want a 13 year old girl
around you wouldn't want to bring a 13
year old girl down to a comedy club
they've got to have a person like a
sailor they've got to have some kids
programs don't they do that let me
finish before you come in here with your
wisdom can you recommend any kind of
book or video class that she can study
I've seen a lot of material but I'm not
sure what will help her get started big
fan and appreciate any suggestions that
you may have and if you read this on the
advice show please give me a heads up I
will have her how the [__] would I give
you I don't know who you are
what is the advice show
a letter here directly from you and not
shittily passed along from her [__]
father and I would like to count how
many mistakes
you made reading this letter I kept the
well you want to talk about mistakes too
when you said at least none that she's
willing you spelled none n-o-n all right
[__] I kept the word small for your
illiterate Ginger ass there's such
arrogant [__] maybe this is why your
daughter doesn't like to share interest
because you're kind of a prick no yes
you know what it is he's worried that
I'm gonna [__] on him so he's gonna [__]
on me first so anyways uh
first of all Emerson College all of a
sudden now you can major in comedy I
heard that tonight yeah which kind of
makes sense considering uh the comedic
legends that have graduated from the
school no just such as Bill Burr just
the tickets that Comics are selling when
I started out
there was a handful of people playing
theaters and that would be like like
George Carlin
Bill Cosby
see I'm already forgetting I mean maybe
those guys that had their TV shows and I
started Seinfeld still hadn't become a
hit yet so he he was probably just
selling out clubs
maybe Roseanne Barr if she gave a [__]
enough at that point because Roseanne
was still going but there was a I mean
it was a short
short list and now there's like a
zillion people out there it seems
They're all playing theaters they're all
right new hours and everything like I
don't there's never been a more prolific
time so I think they've finally seen it
when like how many [__] Comics have
sold out Madison Square Garden like that
was like it was like Eddie Murphy did it
Dice Clay did it
and then Dane Cook did it so there was
like a [__] there was two guys in the
80s nobody in the 90s that I knew of no
comic in the 90s that I know of that
that wasn't well Eddie had already
stopped
dice maybe did it in 1990. but uh
Seinfeld
yeah he was doing the show
um
that was when a lot of yeah Comics were
doing their own TV shows yeah Tim Allen
yeah I don't know how it happened but
all of a sudden now you know there's
like
like I think I know like five people
that sold the [__] thing out so it
might it's now a uh it's for it's
finally I think it's comedy well maybe
that they're having as like comedy
writing in that but I always look at it
as like being a comedian it's actually a
a it's a career now where people used to
kind of look at it even though it always
was a career but it was always kind of
viewed as like it was a stepping stone
to get a sitcom I find it strange that
like major in comedy it's cool but it's
like it's such a weird thing so they're
probably it's weird do you have to be
funny in like your application and [__]
like that right exactly they probably do
like the acting program where you have
to do some material they probably study
all like the history of Comedy from the
very beginning like Vaudeville up until
now they watch a ton of specials they
probably have to write so kind of like
when I did Emerson and I graduated with
a media arts degree right we watched a
shitload of movies we wrote a lot of
papers about it that's probably what
they're gonna do they have to do some
sort of performance right well right now
like I would say well his question was
what can you do now I would just say
what city are they do they say what city
they're in I don't know listen I would
just say just watch as many comedians as
you can or watch as many comedies as you
can uh depending if you want to be a
writer or something like that I mean
these are the fun years like there's no
like you're 13. I mean it's not like
exactly it'll probably change it should
be enjoy no but it should be enjoyable
it should be enjoyable yeah why are you
trying to make it a career for her
already no she loves her no I know I
know I'm just joking but also um they do
improv classes for people that age
that's a good fun thing to do don't do
don't take an improv class at 13. that's
like teaching a kid how to throw a
[__] curveball he's the two young
well if you try to teach a kid when he's
too young to throw a curveball they need
let me finish we just [__]
interrupted me here they're [__] uh
they get the Tommy John surgery
yeah you are that's your pout face is
this yeah I was trying I had a nice
[__] reference there about throwing
the curveball it was going well and you
you were jumping in on me so I decided
to defend myself and now you know what's
gonna happen you're gonna [__] you're
within
three more dumb things of me saying of
doing that thing where you cross your
arms and you [__] look in the other
direction my arms are already half crap
I know yeah and then I say what's wrong
and you go nothing nothing's wrong
something's wrong you got your [__]
arms crossed I don't understand what her
going to an improv class is is why is
that a bad idea
because a lot of those improv theaters
they also do comedy writing workshops
and all that kind of stuff I'll tell you
what because anybody she learned how to
perform in comedy and their job is to
teach 13 year olds how to do improv they
stink they married a rich guy and
they're [__] bored and now they think
oh maybe this is my talent and they're
going to teach him more [__] this is
this is what you have a teacher it's not
when I was 13. not when you were 13.
[__] that this is what you do
hang out with your friends and joke
around and be funny and find out the
movies that you know make your
generation laugh just do that just this
this is the this should be fun it should
be fun yeah it's a good point shouldn't
be you know turning this into like the
sports dads which was the reference
where they teach them how to throw a
[__] curveball at 13 and the movement
that you do when you throw it you snap
in your wrists like that the tendons in
their arms are still growing or whatever
I don't know what it is medically but
they their arm is not strong enough to
do it and these kids need Tommy John
surgery which is basically you take a
ligament out of your [__] leg and
replace it in the elbow from they should
be skipping rocks across the a [__]
Lake you know the advice that I gave no
you're absolutely right the vice I gave
holy [__] can you say that again
what that's all right I have a recording
good oh when I said that you're right
you said absolutely right I don't think
I've ever heard that uh the advice I
just gave is the kind of advice my my
dad would give where he'd be like we'll
get into a class and take this and do
this writing thing and he would make it
this whole big stage thing well there's
a time and place for that and it's not
when you're 13. 13. yeah you should be
walking home from school if they didn't
have your [__] believing there's a
pedophile behind every [__] tree you
should be goofing off with your friends
and and just
you should know how to make people laugh
you should just be [__] making people
laugh you don't want to break it down
and be like oh I just made my my 13 year
old friend laugh let's see let's look at
the setup and what was the punch line
you're gonna start doing right oh here
comes my you know what I'm gonna do
today at school you know what I do today
yeah 13. I'm gonna work on my
misdirections
dad you wouldn't believe it I tagged
this whole thing about the lunch lady
you don't want to do that just [__]
have [__] all the fun out of it exactly
just I would say
watch the legends of today like Melissa
McCarthy Kristen Wiig what what the [__]
you're into and uh
you know I don't know I don't know what
to tell you that's what I would do yeah
I'm a sticker in a [__] comedy class
oh Jesus
[Laughter]
comedy what is it
Webster's Dictionary
comedy as
[Laughter]
what is this thing that we call comedy
all right vegetarian barbecue okay oh
Billy boy the pipes the pipes are
calling uh there you go there's
something new Oh Billy boy I'll do
justice the pipes the pipe shot quality
who's that song I was singing because
you keep watching the [__] repeats of
True Detective
[Laughter]
[__] phenomenal show I can't wait to
see uh
Vince and that guy from the phone booth
movie oh my God you said the phone booth
wow oh the sushi restaurant you're
really reaching back into Colin
Farrell's uh IMDb page with phone booth
I don't see movies that's the last one I
saw and I just saw that to be like how
did these cheap [__]
with the guy standing in their phone but
it wasn't in a Time Square or something
like that so it wasn't cheap
to shoot that I know and it was a phone
booth and it was like 2003 and they
didn't exist anymore
um I like your impression of that song
the theme song from True Detective do it
again why because I love it no I love
this song too until you watched every
episode 500 times I'd be just walking
around my the house
oh God she's watching another one that
is the handsome family a husband and
wife band who do that music and they
also do the the theme to the new season
and they're amazing and I love their
music now I love that gothicy kind of
Becomes Eclectic oh I am oh I'm so KCRW
with it right now
sorry you sound like a high right now
all right oh I wish vegetarian barbecue
Oh Billy boy the price of pipes are
calling uh last Sunday my girlfriend
dragged me to a vegetarian barbecue full
disclosure I was told that there would
be grilled chicken skewers
uh there but I didn't see a single one
this sounds like something in Silver
Lake and we got there on time maybe
that's how they lure people over exactly
it's vegetarian barbecue terrible that's
like hey let's go to this gay sex orgy I
swear to God there's gonna be some
hetero action going on over there
and everybody's banging me in the ass
and I was just like
have I been duped here I really want a
long way to make that point sorry
um you have to bring your own food to
[__] like this yeah
all right instead I you should have
brought the biggest [__] reddish
steak he could find it's it's slapped it
on right next to their dumb portobello
mushrooms yeah what's up [__] sound
managed
I know I'm gonna die before you but I
can look myself from the aisle when I do
whatever dumb things meat eater sick not
like I don't eat meat and alien I'm not
dumb
but I like vegetables all right
I didn't see a single one in the time
instead I only saw vegetable skewers
grilled corn in a bowl of orzo I don't
want to know what that is it's a grain
it's like it's like rice pilaf that's
what it tastes like oh is that gonna be
the new craze orzo the new craze
something very pretentious side and
wheat pita bread not even regular Pita
they couldn't even give me that
I feel bad for them there's nothing
worse when somebody [__] with the food
the only saving grace were a key lime
pie okay and chips and dip and some
decent beer that's pretty good that's
pretty strong uh I could maybe forgive
the veggie barbecue if the people
holding it weren't the most obnoxious
hipsters of course they were both
artists shocker and painful to listen to
as they clatter on about about their
vinyl collection and knowledge of
obscure sci-fi shows again did this take
place in Silver Lake OH Brooklyn or
Williamsburg yeah but those aren't the
only two hipster places yeah that's true
the guy even has this weird nub of a
ponytail coming out of the bottom of his
head he's so cool he can't even have a
normal ponytail uh anyways is it against
the laws of men to have a barbecue
without grilling any meat be it Burgers
dogs brats Etc nothing anything
nothing anything against vegetarian see
at the time not half the time but a
third of the time that's the way they
write it not my dumb [__] brain
nothing anything against
what is he trying to say that not that I
have anything against vegetarians or
their closet diets but I feel like
something has to die for a barbecue to
go on wondering what your thoughts are
on this subject's thanks and go frog
yourself
um
yeah you basically went to a barbecue
where all they had was the sides
you know what I mean they had the
zucchini and they had all that type of
[__] um I though I think a mistake that
vegetarians make is they try to replace
classic meat dishes yeah that's like if
you want to was it tofurkey tofuki like
it's like the fake turkey yeah don't try
to be turkey unless you're Turkey right
right
yeah like a steak doesn't try to be
zucchini exactly because it could never
it could never be you could never be
zucchini zucchini needs to follow its
voice
no if they had it I mean if they had any
kind of common decency they would have a
separate little Hibachi for the the meat
eaters I don't have sympathy for this
guy he knew what it was they said it was
they did lie to him about the chicken we
have a little bit of chicken or
something like that but you have to
bring your own food to these type of
things you can't rely on on them you
gotta bring your own [__] and just bring
it cooked because yeah I was just saying
yeah throw the steak on next to their
dumb pork but they'll be like no no no I
don't want it on the same thing like
dude you just gotta bring your own [__]
you know when this when this idea was
presented to him his inner voice said
I don't go to that [__] [__] yeah you
got to listen to that sir and then you
won't have to hang out with these people
if I was ever invited to a vegan or
vegetarian barbecue I would say no do
you remember that time we had the
vegetarian Thanksgiving we try to do
that oh God my family revolted against
me and that's how I learned my lesson
yeah I was like I want to do a vegan
thing it'll be just as delicious it
wasn't just as delicious it was awful
but we also didn't know how to do it
yeah and we were trying to be really
healthy we had just moved to LA blah
blah blah it's a couple of douchebags
and had we had a douchebag Thanksgiving
was that when I spilled half of the
stuffing behind the stove and started
crying was that that year
I think so oh no no no no we made a
vegetarian lasagna one Thanksgiving oh
God it was a terrible idea it's awful
those [__] carrots in there yeah
carrots carrots and lasagna terrible
awful so then I then you know what uh
Jamie Masada down the Laugh Factory
has this thing where he feeds the
homeless people down there and he asked
me if I wanted to do it and I was like
no man it's my Thanksgiving I I don't
want to I don't you know I did it a
couple times it's just like I don't want
to [__] go down there and then you
have to go on stage he always talks into
going on stage and you're sitting there
and there's a bunch of homeless people
eating and they don't give a [__] and
you grow up and you bomb
last time I was there I remember me and
Ian Edwards just [__] eight it's
funny to eat it on Thanksgiving you know
it's a nice idea thank you it's great on
paper on paper too in a comedy show
they're fine they're fine with just the
food yeah they don't need yeah they
don't need to be like hey how you so how
you guys doing not good we're homeless
is it at least open bar do they get hey
drinks out of it where are you guys from
the [__] Rail Yard
um what bus station do you sleep at
that's what you do you have to switch up
all your references yeah this guy must
sleep in the bus station out there in
Burbank and all the other homeless
people looking down on it because they
sleep in one in [__] Hollywood
so I ended up telling you because the
vegetarian dinner was so bad I said hey
I'm gonna go down and go feed the
Homeless because right that's right
because right next door sneaky son of a
[__] and they went to green black and
you ate a Thanksgiving turkey dinner and
I wolfed it down and I felt so [__]
guilty nah and then I ran over to the
Laugh Factory completely full and a big
smile on my face and I fed some homeless
people and Jamie's like you want to go
on stage they go no he's like come on
buddy that's gonna be fun it's like
Jamie I'm not going up and eating my
balls in front of these [__] people
they they they're good they're good with
the food oh come on man come on man now
you did the right thing by by having a
full uh
but me helping the homeless was was
horseshit that year I I did not do it I
went I didn't go down there because I
had to help the homeless I went down
there because I wanted a [__] turkey
dinner
um all right what are we up to here as
far as time 22 minutes we did 35 so I'm
up to 57. all right dilemma
uh another redhead joke hey who would
know who who would have thought would
you let P Diddy
or anyone else that matter hit you in
the head with a kettlebell for 50
million dollars no
understand the point of these like
random scenario questions that people
like to pose like would you rather get
[__] me
and buy us that's funny
oil like give you an um or something
it's funny though if it's it's a if
they're funny scenarios you give you
give somebody two awful choices he just
said that was one yeah it wasn't a
dilemma would you do that would you let
P Diddy and why why is P Diddy in it
why is that what does that have to do
with it this is the thing where people
pull things out of their ass that I have
a problem with it's lazy it's like would
you let P Diddy hit you in the head of
the Kettlebell for 50 million bucks like
what are you 13 yeah but I said no a lot
of people would say yes oh just because
it for the money
no if I wasn't doing what I was doing
for a living and if I wasn't comfortable
then yeah I'd let him drop it on my toe
yeah but I'm doing all right so uh no
I don't have 50 million but I don't have
anyone near that that's just but I mean
I'm not doing that and then somebody
videotapes it oh that big [__] cattle
belt failed for the rest of my [__]
life that was the entire that was the
entire question I gotta be honest with
you I wouldn't want to make it that way
um
no I wouldn't want to make it that way
were you talking about make what what
way like all of a sudden you get 50
million bucks
with a kettlebell and you get a little
Tweed coat on or some [__] and then
you're going to some party where
everybody else has 50 million bucks
and they're like oh you know I'm a
[__] uh
I don't know what are they [__] I'm a
banker oh I I ran a Ponzi scheme you
know something that took a little bit of
effort American Greed
American Greed
um I just find when people ask dumb
questions like that that are meant to be
some sort of probation
it didn't work it didn't work let me
give you the lemonade it's like it's
you're not deep
yeah you're being really harsh am I on
the Dilemma guy
all right he took he took it he took a
swing well I don't want people to come
with a little bit more effort that's all
is it is it so wrong that I demand
excellence
I'm full of [__] right now what's the
Dilemma you want to post to me then all
right let me give you a good one would
you rather uh
uh uh I don't know any famous people's
[__] names so I'm gonna have to
describe them to you oh God this should
be good
I'm trying to think I love when you
would you try to identify actors
just
all right would you rather have sex with
uh
uh I can't even think of anybody
who's just a [__] just somebody you
wouldn't want to have sex with
an actor or like no one astronaut
who's gonna relate other than this [__]
uh okay the guy in seven who got
force-fed the [__] SpaghettiOs oh my
god do you want to [__] him and he's in
that makeup
and when he [__] he goes or
or
or uh
put some jam on yahuha and let some sort
of animal lick it off
you have to bang the [__] spaghetti
okay until completion
and uh and then he spends the night
you can put some Jam no I'm gonna go on
Yahoo oh
that'll be over that'll be over it and
it'll be over
37 seconds I could not be involved in
the sexual situation with an animal on
any level 28 seconds it's over I will go
with the fat guy spending the night I'm
not gonna get into any kind of
bestiality no no no no no no no no no
nothing you let it do it to you for 10
seconds
the animal
oh my God you're disgusting
no nothing with an animal no absolutely
not nothing ever wasn't that funny that
was funny there you go see but that
wasn't funny well [__] she's not a
[__] comedian well you what you're
gonna do is you're gonna make everybody
gun shy to [__] take a big swing and
everybody has a swing and a miss no no
no no no they're gonna like tweet and
send in all kinds of crazy dilemmas now
which actually should be kind of fun I
just don't like it when they just don't
make any sense and I actually just gave
you a hacky one because they're always
sexual so like I because when we were
doing the dilemmas what happens it just
became it just it just kept going sex
would you rather [__] your mom the
[__] dead it's like
just like Jesus Christ
um it's like watch one of those Comedy
Central roasts where like by the time
you get up if you're like ninth on one
of the things like the level of mean you
have to be especially because all of
those [__] roasts so many of them
were just like the the comics roasting
the person didn't know him so they
didn't have any personal stories so it
was just you know everyone one of those
same stake but one of these dilemmas or
the would you rather scenarios like what
are these things attempting to prove
like yeah if someone's like would you
rather have sex with your mom to be
funny I was just supposed to be like I'm
I'm looking too much into it all right
yeah fair enough oh would you rather
wash dishes at Denny's
or wipe the syrup off the tables at IHOP
syrup off the tables third shift for a
year
third shift when all the drunks come in
it's the fights when the YouTube videos
get made or Denny's you got the
afternoon ship from two to five and you
just gotta wash all these [__] plates
but they're left over they're left over
from the morning and the lunch rush wipe
off the tables but but you're done two
to five two to five or you gotta work a
full [__] eight hours you come in at
10 o'clock at night and you're done at
six in the morning
but all I have to do is wipe down tables
yeah wipe down tables
and then the other option is [__]
hours or you just wash dishes for three
hours and and you have your whole
[__] morning to yourself and the
whole night like I may have to all right
I might have to change that then
knows a lot of [__] dishes
no at Denny's at Denny's a lot of dried
syrup you know what I mean ketchup and
all that yeah people you have to like
scrape off the plates first too and all
that [__] you know like the bus boys
they just put down oh you wait you wait
three months anyway you got to clean out
the [__] grease trap that's something
you'll never forget oh no I'm sticking
with the wiping down of the tables
because I can kind of have fun I can
like chat with people I don't want to
stand back there for three hours but and
people like I've seen people blow their
nose and like put the napkin like on the
plate and all kinds of disgusting [__]
like I'm not touching that oh I put on a
pair of gloves and I'll wipe down the
table spray some [__] antiseptic or
whatever disinfect when you get home at
six you leave at six you get home at
seven in the [__] morning you're so
[__] wired you can't go to bed until
ten or eight and then you [__] sleep
until what three four o'clock in the
afternoon then you gotta go back in at
10 it's just so you have no [__] life
feel like one of those like that guy
who's in the paparazzi movie
hey I'm gonna take your picture and then
kill my friend
[Laughter]
I'll take a picture and kill my friends
I love that movie too wasn't it called
Paparazzi nocturnal nightmares
um oh did I have Cole Hauser in it
no that one it was whole it was it was
it was the one uh
it was the um
it was the one with Goran
something like that a tennis player
I'm one of those crazy Jake Gyllenhaal
oh
Jake Gyllenhaal yeah night night stalker
Nightcrawler Nightcrawler you were you
were describing Nightcrawler this whole
time yeah I'm gonna take your picture
and I'm gonna kill my friend
what'd you think I was talking about
a single white female
I thought there was a movie called
Paparazzi like a real movie called
Paparazzi oh yeah wasn't that Cole house
Cole Hauser mm-hmm
okay okay
all right here's a deal
would you rather get slapped in the face
by Cole Hauser
I'll grab the SpaghettiOs guy give you a
hug naked
[Music]
[Laughter]
let him slap you in the it's gonna end
up on YouTube
because I feel like it might lead to
something else on one of those
you know I'm so tired let me give a [__]
that you said that
she's all yours Cole go ahead you want
to deal with this [__] thing or have
the naked guy from Seven give me a joke
these are good no because if you
actually chose the hug then I was gonna
add while he softly wept into the nape
of your neck
oh
I have to ask you one now oh Jesus okay
would you rather
uh
uh take an etiquette class with Martha
Stewart Martha Stewart I was trying to
think of things I hang with her in a
second or
uh would you rather hey Martha what was
it like when you went to jail
or would you rather uh do a dance
recital with Ellen DeGeneres
oh my God no no [__] there's no
there's not even a uh you wouldn't want
to do a dance recital with Alan you'd
rather sit through an etiquette class
with Martha Stewart no I I
because I know she's a [__] stand-up
comic yeah and maybe she did it a couple
times because she thought it was fun and
now they expected to do it right so now
she has to do it and now she's good
people coming up to her in restaurants
like I love to dance oh yeah and she
probably hates it yeah it probably
thinks about murder suicide every
[__] time it happens I see it in her
eyes I when I watched that a part of me
dies
part of my soul [__] dies when I
every time I watch her [__] do that
it's just like it's your show you don't
have to do that
would you rather be grilled about your
comedy by Oprah Winfrey or
the or or
just guest host on The View
all the view is the uh yes
oh I could have with whoopee and I think
it's Rosie Perez is on there now I would
have so much fun on The View I would
just keep bringing up feminist things
and just say I don't understand what the
problem is just to see how mad I could
make Joey Behar she's not on there
anymore or is she I don't know I don't
know I don't I would just I would just
act like a [__] idiot and be like no
I'm just asking
would you rather go on the road with Guy
Fieri
eating all the food and just doing all
that with him getting sunburned
sunburn or uh would you
I'm already out
because I wouldn't want to get in the
car with him afterwards and hear what he
says about all those with Jesus Christ
that [__] suck man and be careful
what you wish for I thought this was
gonna be [__] fun I mean I know I'm
making money and everything but hey if I
eat one more [__] sloppy joe I swear
to God oh would you rather dress up like
Mario Batali and like you know go to
book signings with him as like a little
comedic uh relief hey is my uh
because that's tied into me as a
comedian I have to get sunburned with
Guy Fieri
I just [__] with them the whole time
just subtly
guy I mean I'm not one to talk about
hair or anything but you know
at the very least can you stop wearing
your sunglasses on the back of your head
I know that was cool why does he do that
because when he's part of that
generation that got the barbed wire
tattoo on your arm doesn't he look like
he was in that van what's that one um
hey now you're a rock star get your game
on go play or whatever
what is the name of that group Smash
Mouth Smash Mouth
he looks like he should be in Smash
Mouth or are they the same ones that
sang Maddie's we'll be walking on this
side
yeah or like Hoobastank or something
like that who was saying is not the same
didn't they sing the reason I think I
like that song I Don't Know
I have no idea I don't know anything
about that whole time during music I was
doing stand-up so much I have no idea
who Hoobastank
three Mary four
Blink 182 I know who they are I like
them I don't know why everybody shits on
Travis Barker as a [__] drummer he's
an incredible drummer he's a [__]
great drummer and everything
I don't I don't know what it was what it
was was there was a lot of young kids
that thought he was the greatest [__]
drummer because he was playing you're in
a pop band so they just knew who he was
right so then all of a sudden because
they thought he was the greatest it's
all of a sudden Travis Barker said he
was better than John Bonham which he
never did so hey how about we met the
drummer from Nine Inch Nails sorry it
interrupts oh yes yes how about we met
the drummer from Nine Inch Nails and his
lovely girlfriend karadi English
who I got hey you name dropping all over
the phone if you watch cycle seven of
America's Next Top Model she won I'm
sorry I'm I'm grilling nerding out right
now but all right you know I've been
we're going way over and we got it early
oh I know we're going out tomorrow all
right all right Nia would you rather
would you rather and not a good one
uh
uh flying a plane around the world
it's a [__] one of those old
propeller ones where you sit in the back
with the single seat right next to the
bathroom and it already smells before it
takes off would you rather do that
or uh
oh Jesus how do I top that one
would you rather do that or uh
I got nothing it's too [__] late ah
jeez it's built don't [__] close like
this
now I'm just thinking of doing something
on a train fly around so fly around the
world in like the worst seat on the
airplane
it's gonna take you like [__] four
days to do it okay either do that or uh
land a lay in a nice comfy bed
that watch American Greeting
land and that's comfy bed watch
Americans let's [__] do that all
right go [__] yourselves I'll talk to
you